[Music]
AET so we're here at the March in DC as
you can see we are to stand still
because it is so crowded right now Demi
Lovato's performing giving an amazing
performance everybody is showing up
right now to say enough is enough gun
violence has to stop
[Music]
skies
oh it's great she's she's a hero man
she's a retort to your two young men and
women out there I think that she's she's
you know she's literally the image of a
recovery and and getting their life
together you know and so I'm I'm excited
that she's there and for this historic
moment for young people - the thing is
obviously that you know this this
generation has been called on to do
bigger things that themselves you know
and I think that when young people
decide to lead into solution we all have
to answer that call you know I couldn't
be more proud of the fact that you know
the grown ups have been trying to create
some kind of solution and all sound the
young kids decided you know let's just
simplify things and say hey this is
enough is enough they have a tool that
we never had growing up which is the
power of social media you know they're
able to communicate to not only their
immediate network but they can actually
make something trend and in it's it's
it's cool it's trendy - to be an
activist today you know it's a that that
is if you're not aware of what's
happening not only in your community but
on a national level in that what it's
affecting you directly you're not you're
not keeping up with your with your own
generation we're waking up to a
generation that understands what needs
to get done and it's about to get it
done themselves yeah how do you feel
about the fact that more celebrities
have stepped up and are now using their
platform to talk about gun violence well
I'm you know look it's interesting
because people like like you and me have
been doing this for you know almost two
decades you know but I think it's an
incredible and beautiful to see that our
network of colleagues and friends have
been able to just join and say okay wait
let me you know politics are human
issues you know when they used to tell
us when we were you know young and
center in the industry oh you're an
actor you don't get involved in politics
but then you realize the policies affect
you know a policy and policy affects
humankind you know and and and it's
really interesting as citizen citizens
as people in general that you actually
get involved so I think that that's why
it's exciting to see that so many people
are lending their voices but most
importantly their platform for other
people's voices because we gotta just be
amplifying the people's you know the
people's word in the people spirit
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]